i just i just choose not to believe in
them okay check this out yeah
can i see your hands yeah okay look at
my hands yeah we have nails yeah do you
do you hate your hands or do you love
your hands
i'm somewhere in between okay
so how could you
find use
and love
yourself
but not love the one who created you
not only does it encourage you to read
it tells you how many verses you've read
how many pages you read how long you've
been on it and best of all the hasanah
counter download the qurani app now and
have a ramadan with allah's book like
you've never had before
assalamu alaikum guys we have here
somebody who has taken covet to the next
level he might be working for the
government are you working for the
government
i can't say he can't say it's on the
cover
bond james bond or you know luke bond
james
how you doing luke i'm doing okay yeah
yeah okay we need to speak a little bit
louder so they can hear you no no no
keep it on keep on it looks cool it's
cool we really like it so now he was
walking down the road and i saw you
and i thought what's going on here is
there a uh uh attack a nuclear attack
what's going to happen you're getting
ready for what is this
uh it's just for a joke this was a joke
yeah okay so who's the joke on is there
someone you're targeting
no it's just um it's just hopefully to
give people a good laugh you know oh
okay interesting so just people that you
have you you caught my eye if you
remember yeah okay now luke you said
that you read the quran
no i never read it i just heard about it
oh you heard about it yeah okay today
i'm going to gift you one
after we're going to talk yeah okay
um now
do you believe in a higher being a
creator
uh no not really you know okay is there
any specific reason why which you have
come to the conclusion
that there is not a higher being
[Music]
no not really i just um i just don't
really like being involved like
religions and stuff okay it's not like a
race thing or anything like that i just
don't really just find religion
interesting okay okay let's put religion
to a side yeah let's talk about as two
logical human beings yeah
when we look around us or when you go
about your day-to-day life you use your
logic right yeah okay so when you woke
up today you woke up believing that he
was in your bedroom and you maybe went
downstairs or you know you know where
your fridge is you know that to make
breakfast you know what you bought what
you've got there and what you're going
to use you know i'm going to use a a
fork or a knife or i'm going to do
peanut butter jam have you peanut butter
jam before um once yeah you need to try
it i never had it before but when i
tried it i was like wow
i tried you really i like i really liked
it yeah so now you use your logic on day
to day basis even when you came out
today you logically said to yourself i
want to have a laugh i want to make
people smile i want to do a little joke
you gave yourself a purpose for that day
to come out and do this and use your
logic do you not ever wonder luke
where did i come from yeah why am i here
sometimes you do one there yeah okay
do you not think to yourself logically
doesn't it follow
that there must have been a cause to you
which is okay your mom and dad but what
is the cause to the whole universe
to us human rings
human beings is large on this planet why
are we here why do like once someone
said i think it's a philosopher he said
why is there something rather than
nothing
you're conscious i'm conscious
so do you not ever wonder there must be
a higher power what's stopping you from
believing in that
nothing really i just don't
i don't know i just i just don't really
like religion all that much you don't
really i don't really like getting
involved with religion okay
my family my family is a catholic but
i'm not okay but luke would you not say
that there is many many reasons to
believe in a higher intelligence yes i
do believe there is yeah okay well one
second then okay what's stopping you
look let's put religion to aside i know
look before i came to islam i for
religion is man-made it's there to
control the masses everybody's saying
i'm right but i had to come to a
realization that realization was the
following i believed in a higher being
but i said how can this higher being
exist by not giving me purpose so you
said you know there are reasons to
believe in a higher being yeah
why do you not believe
i just choose not to
okay that's very interesting man so you
do believe there are signs and evidence
to and higher intelligence but you
refuse to worship him or you do you
refuse to worship him or do you refuse
to
acknowledge that he exists
i just refuse to worship him okay why
it's very interesting
why do you like do you believe it's not
worthy or or can it be luke that you
have a perception of god in your mind or
something that you have been through
that has made you feel like he's not
worthy of worship maybe
so what what's what's what's stopping
you from not wanting to worship him
[Music]
honestly
um
i just i just choose not to believe in
them okay check this out yeah
can i see your hands yeah okay look at
my hands yeah we have nails yeah do you
do you hate your hands or do you love
your hands
somewhere in between okay so
your eyes that you see with
the tongue that you taste with yeah your
faculties as a human being would you say
that you are like happy in the context
where you know they they they bring you
some kind of joy when eating food you
know
yes okay
so how could you
find use
and love yourself
but not love the one who created you it
doesn't make sense in the context where
how could you say wow my hands they
helped me to grab things yeah
how could you find useful in something
like your being your hand how could you
love your hands but not love the one who
created them we wouldn't add up
you know i'm trying to say yeah so if
you think about it if you acknowledge
that god almighty is the one that's
given all this to you all these
faculties he's the one who sustains you
he's the one who provides food for you
and wultan all these kind of things yeah
does that not make you feel like he is
worthy of worship
when you put it like that yes okay good
so now what that means luke is that
and anyone's watching this what that
means is
because we do not ponder deep enough and
think about it and sometimes what
happens is we may have gone through some
trauma in our life and we ascribe that
to god and that's why we say i don't
want to worship that god because it's
made me suffer argument say
but reflecting and pondering upon it
allah says in the quran i'll recite you
allah says
in the creation of the heavens and the
earth and in the alternation of the
night and day there are signs for those
who have
logic thinking so
you i i admire you honestly by the way
yeah i really i'm very happy to talk to
you seem like a very sensitive
it's a it's not because i'm i hate
religion or anything like that people
can believe whatever they believe in i
just choose not to believe it
you definitely have that right but
thinking about and discussing now you do
seem sincere you do accept that there
are signs that god exists and you did
say that you do not believe that you
want to worship him even though you
believe it exists but when we broke it
down that the things that he's done for
us and things that he does you do accept
that he is worthy of worship okay from
now onwards would you still say you are
someone that believes in god but doesn't
worship him or would you say you're
someone i'm somewhere in the middle okay
would you say for example that we can
get you to the side where you believe in
god and accept that he's worthy of
worship and you're going to start a
journey maybe just trying to acquire
that
yes yeah i think that's a good start and
that's i'm not putting words in your
mouth that's if you believe that yeah
because you did say that because come on
how could we are you ungrateful to your
mom and dad no i love my woman why do
you love your mum and dad because they
because they're the ones that look up to
me all my life what about the one who
gave you your mom and dad and the one
that looks after you till this day that
would be my grandparents no no no no
whatever i'm talking about god almighty
your great-great-grandparents yeah so
for example your mum and dad they go out
to work for the food yeah yeah but
only my dad goes out to work
all day that's good that's good that's a
quite traditional way of muslim
household yeah the the thing is here
that what about the resources that we
have now some people come and say oh go
to i work for it no you don't because
the water that we have why is it so
clean for us to drink who made it like
that
why why is our water clean for us to
drink
i'm trying to say who has who has given
it that functionality that it is good
for us the food that we eat why has it
got nutritions why has he got stuff that
benefits us
why is it that when a baby is born that
it's the first thing that he wants to do
is suckle and the mother has the breast
the milk
is that a coincidence no so what we're
trying to say is these are all
attributed to god almighty
because if he exists and he's created us
he has his mercy is all around us i'm
trying to say so based on that we need
to understand and accept that because of
who he is he's deserving of our worship
i'm trying to say yeah so i will give
you a quran i'm going to leave you on
this i don't want to hold you do you
have any questions for me uh no okay
what i'm going to do is this yeah can
you just hold this yeah
it's a microphone actually you know what
you do this open the quran
okay let's open the quran anyway and
point out point out to a verse to me
this one
your protector and he is the best of
helpers
yeah we will okay so this is here it
says but allah is your protector and he
is the best of helpless
so as you can see this very specific
verse yeah here it's telling you that he
is your protector and he is your helper
well what was we talking about here of
who he is and what he does for us and
that's what if he's worthy of worship or
not yeah i'm going to give this to you
as a gift but what allah subhanahu wa
tala is saying in here is that he is
your helper and your protector meaning
that he provides for you and we even
believe there are angels that protect
you from harm you know what i'm trying
to say so i believe luke that you know
you should look into this and if he
exists if you know he exists and he is
deserving of worship because of
everything he does for us
pray to him you've got nothing to lose
go home and say look
god if you're there guide me to the
truth i'm confused
i know you're there okay i'm in the
middle maybe you're worthy of worship
okay we'll discuss that but guide me to
the truth can you do that yes luke thank
you very much any more questions no
thank you very much it's a pleasure we'd
like to see you with more costumes yes
no problem thank you very much
youtube uh youtube channel it'll be uh
i'll give it to you my name is ali dawa
[Music]
so
uh yes but not today it might be an idea
so right my name ali ali
are you train driver
come talk to us
yeah that's my channel
yeah
yeah no problem it's been a pleasure
look man look after yourself make sure
you read the quran yeah
i mean guys as you can see we're having
nice honest question uh discussions here
and i find it very profound that he
accepts that there are signs for god but
he was like i don't believe he's
deserving of worship
after some reflection he realized that
god almighty
is deserving of worship and we discussed
that today and this is what we're doing
yes come let's talk about it
how do you look after yourself thank you
so as you can see uh guys we are causing
we just want people to reflect the fitra
is there we're just trying to reignite
it and that's what happened today he
acknowledged that how could he love his
body parts but not love the one who
created those so hopefully i'll also
plan on that guide to him you can
support us at paypal in the link
inshallah salaam so we can carry on
these works till next time
assalamualaikum today
you